♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT" THERE'S
NOTHING IN THE WORLD WORSE THAN
FINDING OUT THAT YOUR DEEPEST
FEARS ARE JUSTIFIED.
TONIGHT THAT IS OUR SCENARIO
MAYBE THERE REALLY IS A ZOMBIE
IN THE CLOSET.
IT LETS SAY THAT YOU ARE A KID
AND YOU'VE CONVINCED YOURSELF
THAT YOUR PARENTS DON'T REALLY
LOVE YOU.
THEY CLAIM THEY SAY IT ALL THE
TIME WITHOUT LOOKING FROM THEIR
iPHONES.
BUT YOU CAN TELL THAT THEY DON'T
REALLY MEAN IT THEY DON'T SEEM
SINCERE.
AND THEN ONE CHRISTMAS MORNING
CONFIRMATION YOU DISCOVER THAT
THEY FORGOTTEN THE BAYOU
PRESENCE.
THEY WERE BUSY AND IT'S UP THEIR
MINDS.
SAID THEY SPENT ALL THEIR TIME
AND ALL THEIR MONEY BUYING GIFTS
FOR A KID DOWN THE STREET SO ALL
THE THINGS THAT YOU ASKED FOR A
GIFT TO ANOTHER 9-YEAR-OLD
YOU'VE NEVER MET.
HOW DOES IT MAKE YOU FEEL?
WILL YOU WOULD BE CRUSHED, BUT
YOU WOULD ALSO BE VINDICATED.
YOU WOULD KNOW FOR A DEAD
CERTAIN FACT THAT YOUR PARENTS
REALLY DIDN'T LOVE YOU THEY ARE
REALLY EVEN THAT INTERESTED IN
YOU.
THAT'S HOW A LOT OF AMERICANS
FELT LAST NIGHT WATCHING THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES
APPROVED YET ANOTHER MASSIVE AID
PACKAGE FOR UKRAINE.
LIKE I GET NOTHING AGAINST
UKRAINE BUT WE COULD PROBABLY
USE THAT MONEY HERE RIGHT ABOUT
NOW.
AFTER A HUNDRED YEARS OF
VIRTUALLY UNINTERRUPTED WEALTH
GENERATION THE AMERICAN ECONOMY
APPEARS TO BE FALTERING IN WAYS
THAT ARE SCARY TO ANYONE IS
PAYING ATTENTION.
EVEN PEOPLE WHO ARE PAYING
ATTENTION CAN SENSE THAT THERE'S
SOMETHING REALLY WRONG.
MOST PEOPLE AREN'T WORKING BUT
THOSE WHO ARE ARE GETTING POORER
QUICKLY THANKS TO INFLATION.
ALL OF A SUDDEN THINGS ARE
WILDLY MORE EXPENSIVE.
WE LITERALLY HAVE A SHORTAGE OF
BABY FORMULA RIGHT NOW, DID YOU
THINK THAT THAT WOULD HAPPEN IN
AMERICA EVER?
AND YET IT IS HAPPENING AND SO
WAS THE DEADLIEST DRUG EPIDEMIC
IN OUR HISTORY.
HUNDRED AND 70,000 OF YOUR
FELLOW AMERICANS MOST OF THEM
YOUNG PEOPLE, SHOULD'VE HAD
YOUNG PRODUCTIVE LIVES.
THEY'VE DIED FROM DRUG OVERDOSES
THE PAST YEAR.
THIS THE SADDEST THING THAT'S
HAPPENED IN OUR COUNTRY FOR A
VERY LONG TIME.
AND YET CONGRESS WHICH CLAIMS TO
RUN THE COUNTRY CAN'T BE
BOTHERED TO ACKNOWLEDGE IT, MUCH
LESS DO ANYTHING.
INSTEAD THE REPRESENTATIVES IN
WASHINGTON JUST VOTED TO SEND
YET ANOTHER $40 BILLION TO
UKRAINIAN ALL THE GUARDS WHO
PAID OFF THE PRESIDENTS SON.
YOU CAN ADD IT TO THE
APPROXIMATELY $14 BILLION
THEY'VE ALREADY SPENT ON
UKRAINE.
THAT BRINGS THE TOTAL AVERAGE
TONIGHT SOME MORE THAN
$50 BILLION.
HOW MUCH IS THAT?
WELL FOR PERSPECTIVE IT IS MORE
THAN WE SPEND PER YEAR ON
AVERAGE ON THE WAR IN
AFGHANISTAN.
A WAR THAT BEGAN WITH A DIRECT
ATTACK ON THE UNITED STATES.
54 BILLION THAT'S ABOUT RUSSIA
THE COUNTRY SPENDS ON ITS ENTIRE
ARMED FORCES OVER THE COURSE OF
A FULL YEAR.
IT IS A LUDICROUS AMOUNT OF
MONEY.
AND YET CONGRESS HAPPILY
APPROVED IT THEY ALLOCATED
$7 BILLION MORE THEN JOE BIDEN
ASKED FOR THAT'S HOW EXCITED
THEY WERE TO DO IT.
SO WHERE IS THIS MONEY GOING?
THAT'S THE BEST PART.
CONGRESS HAS DECIDED TO FIX ALL
DEPRESSING PROBLEMS THAT HAVE TO
BE FIXED EXCEPT FIXING THEM IN
UKRAINE AND NOT HERE.
SO THE MAIN COURSE OF ALL OF
THIS FUNDING FROM DAY ONE HAS
BEEN TO SECURE UKRAINE.
BECAUSE YOU CAN HAVE A COUNTRY
WITHOUT BORDERS THEY HAVE TO BE
SECURE.
NANCY PELOSI STRONGLY BELIEVES
THAT ABOUT UKRAINE SO HERE'S
WHAT YOU THINK SOME THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE.
THE BORDER SECURITY IS THE MAIN
GOAL.
THEN THERE'S THE PROBLEM OF
INSECURITY IN UKRAINE THINGS ARE
GETTING EXPENSIVE AND YOU PRANCE
OVER TO SPEND $760 MILLION TO
SPEND THAT.
AND NOT JUST IN UKRAINE,
CONGRESS WAS STILL KIND OF
SPORTY THEY ALSO ADDED HUNDRED
AND $50 MILLION FOR SOMETHING
CALLED THE GLOBAL AGRICULTURE
AND FOOD SECURITY PROGRAM
BECAUSE WHILE WERE FEEDING
UKRAINE US WITHOUT MORE FOOD
THAN WE CAN USE.
AND OF COURSE THAT WILL
OBVIOUSLY INCLUDE BABY FORMULA
TOO BECAUSE KIDS IN OTHER
COUNTRIES NEED TO EAT.
AND THEN THERE'S ANOTHER HUGE
CHUNK OF CAST TO COMBAT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
NOT HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND TEXAS
WHERE IT'S NOW YOU BAKED IT WAS
THANKS TO THE OPEN BORDERS WITH
MEXICO.
TO COMBAT IT IN UKRAINE.
IT'S SAD WHAT'S HAPPENING THERE.
WERE IGNORING IT.
THEY'RE STILL MORE MONEY TO MAKE
SURE THAT UKRAINIANS HAVE
EMERGENCY SHELTER BECAUSE
APPARENTLY MORE THAN A MILLION
AMERICANS ARE HOMELESS TONIGHT.
THERE'S 900 MILLION TO MAKE SURE
THAT UKRAINIANS ARE ABLE TO
ENTITLED TO ACCESS PROGRAMS.
IN OTHER WORDS YOU CAN AFFORD TO
FILL UP YOUR TRUCK BUT YOU KNOW
IF THE PAY THE LIVING EXPENSIVE
WHEN SOMEONE CLAIMS TO BE IN
YOUR COUNTRY WHO CLAIMS TO BE
UKRAINE AND YOU WILL.
THE BECAUSE PAYING OFF YOUR
FRIEND IS ALWAYS THE REAL POINT
OF THESE EXERCISES IN WASHINGTON
THERE ARE BILLIONS MORE DOLLARS
FROM THEIR EMPLOYERS.
THAT WOULD INCLUDE $72 MILLION
FOR SOMETHING THE BILL DESCRIBES
AS "RESEARCH DEVELOPMENT AND
EVALUATION IN UKRAINE."
HONESTLY THIS IS WEIRD UKRAINE
IS A WAR ZONE AND THEY'RE
PROBABLY NOT A GREAT PLACE FOR
SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH RIGHT NOW,
BUT WHATEVER.
WERE FINDING SOME KIND OF SIGN
EXPERIMENT IN UKRAINE AND MORE
QUESTIONS FROM YOU.
AND THE BILL GOES ON LIKE THIS,
AND ON, AND ON.
CONGRESS IS NOW SPENT MORE MONEY
ON UKRAINE IN SIX MONTHS THAN
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT SPENT ON ALL
ROADS AND ALL BRIDGES IN THE
UNITED STATES OVER ALL OF
AUSTRIA.
THE $40 BILLION WERE SENDING TO
UKRAINE SO THEY CAN SECURE THE
BORDERS BY THE WAY IS MORE THAN
DOUBLE, MORE THAN DOUBLE WHAT
JOE BIDEN HAS ASKED TO FUND
CUSTOMS AND BORDER SECURITY IN
UNITED STATES.
ONE BILL MORE THAN DOUBLE WHAT
WERE SPENDING.
AND THEN IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS
HISTORIC DRUG EMERGENCY THE BILL
SPENDS MORE THAN TEN TIMES THE
ENTIRE BUDGET OF THE DEA.
MORE THAN TEN TIMES.
JUST IN CASE YOU'RE WONDERING
HOW YOUR LEADERS FEEL ABOUT YOU.
THEY'RE NOT FAIR AT ALL NOW WE
KNOW FOR SURE.
YOU SHOULD KNOW THAT EVERY
SINGLE DEMOCRAT IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES ODOR FOR THIS
BILL THAT WOULD INCLUDE EVEN
BARBARA LEAH BERKELEY.
SHE WAS THE ONLY MEMBER OF
CONGRESS TO OPPOSE THE WAR
AGAINST THE TALIBAN.
BUT A WORN UKRAINE ASSUMING THAT
SHE BELIEVES TO SUPPORT WHY?
BECAUSE THERE'S NO POTENTIAL
CHANCE THAT WAR COULD HELP
UNITED STATES.
THERE'S A REASON.
>> THIS WAR IS NOT ONLY ABOUT
UKRAINE THIS WAR IS THE REST THE
WORLD.
VLADIMIR PUTIN TRYING TO
ESTABLISH THE AUTOCRATIC
GOVERNMENT THROUGHOUT THE WORLD
WE KNOW THAT THIS IS TAKING
PLACE THROUGH DISINFORMATION
CAMPAIGNS.
ALL KINDS OF MISINFORMATION IS
TAKING PLACE.
>> Tucker: SO IT'S NOT REALLY
ABOUT UKRAINE IT'S ABOUT
SOMETHING BIGGER THAN UKRAINE
THANKS BARBARA LEE FOR BEING
DUMB ENOUGH TO TELL US THAT AND
SAY IT OUT LOUD.
THIS IS A WAR ON DISINFORMATION.
WHICH AT SOME POINT IN SOME WAY
IS DEAD CERTAIN TO BE A WAR ON
YOU.
NO QUESTION ABOUT.
WE KNOW FOR CERTAIN THAT WARS
AGAINST THINGS YOU CAN'T REALLY
IDENTIFY AGAINST PEOPLE WHO
DON'T EXIST WARS AGAINST
CONCEPTS, ONE THING ABOUT THOSE
WARS LIKE THE WORN TERROR THAT
THEY LAST FOREVER.
SO IT'S A LITTLE WEIRD TO SEE
TIM RYAN OF OHIO VOTE FOR THIS.
HE WAS SUPPOSED TO BE A WORKING
MAN'S DEMOCRAT.
A GUY WHO CARES ABOUT
BREAD-AND-BUTTER ISSUES,
TIM RYAN REPRESENTS YOUNG PEOPLE
IN AKRON.
TAKE A LOOK AT AKRON SOMETIME.
I TOOK A WAR ZONE ITSELF.
THESE ARE THE CITIES THAT BUILT
AMERICA CRUMBLING AND DESPERATE
NOW FROM TOTAL NEGLECT.
BUT DON'T YOU WORRY TIM RYAN IS
TOTALLY COMMITTED.
AND SO IS NANCY PELOSI.
FUNDING UKRAINE AT ANY COST IS
MORE THAN A FOREIGN POLICY
OBJECTIVE IT'S KIND OF RELIGIOUS
OBSERVER.
>> THE BRUTALITY OF
VLADIMIR PUTIN IS JUST NOT WHAT
HE'S DOING IN UKRAINE BUT THE
IMPACT THAT IT IS HAVING ON FOOD
FOR THE WORLD.
SO WHEN YOUR HOME THINKING WHAT
IS THIS ALL ABOUT, THINK ABOUT
WHEN I WAS HUNGRY YOU FED ME.
>> Tucker: OH, SO WANTS TO
SEND MORE MISSILES TO UKRAINE
AND THE MORE MISSILES WE SENT TO
UKRAINE AND THE LESS HUNGRY
PEOPLE ARE TO BE.
WAIT A SECOND, WOULDN'T WANT TO
DO EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO BRING
AN END TO THE WAR IN UKRAINE?
HOW DARE YOU QUOTE THAT BOOK.
THERE WAS A TIME WHEN
NANCY PELOSI DIDN'T WANT TO
SPEND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS SICK
TO SECURE COUNTRIES BORDER.
IT WAS NOT LONG AGO IT WAS APRI.
SHE WAS SUPPOSED TO ATTEND.
WHAT CHANGED?
WATCH.
>> THE WALL AND MY VIEW IS
EXPENSIVE, UNWISE, AND WHEN THE
PRESIDENT SAID WILL I PROMISE TO
WALL DURING MY CAMPAIGN I THINK
HE SAID HE WAS IN A PASA
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF COST OF
THE WALL ONTO THE TAXPAYER.
>> Tucker: DID YOU CATCH THAT
BORDER SECURITY IN THE
UNITED STATES IS IMMORAL.
BUT HE STRONGLY ENCOURAGEMENT
FOR BORDER SECURITY IN UKRAINE.
THEY ARE UNITED ON THIS POINT.
THEY STAND AS ONE, ALSO AS USUAL
A STAINED PROPAGANDA CAMPAIGN OF
THE MEDIA HAS MANAGED TO DIVIDE
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
NOW WHY DOES THIS HAPPEN EVERY
SINGLE TIME?
HERE IS WHY, BECAUSE HOW
CONSERVATIVE THEY TELL YOU THEY
ARE THEY BELIEVE
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
THEY CARE DEEPLY WHAT LEGACY
MEDIA SAYS.
THEY READ "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
EVERY DAY THEY DON'T BE
CRITICIZED.
THAT'S HOW THE LEFT CONTROLS
EVERY SINGLE TIME.
IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE IT THINK
BACK THE LAST TWO YEARS YOU SAW
THE SAME DYNAMIC IN THE EARLY
DAYS OF THE BLM RIOTS AND THE
COVID LOCKDOWNS.
NANCY PELOSI WAS OUT THERE TAKEN
THE MOST EXTREME POSSIBLE
POSITION AND A LOT OF REPUBLICAN
LEADERS AGREED WITH HER.
FORMER GOVERNOR SHE TOLD
AMERICANS AND THE FIRST DAYS THE
RIOTS THAT THEY DESERVE TO
SUFFER AFTER GEORGE FLOYD DIED.
IN ORDER TO HEAL AND NEEDS TO BE
PERSONAL AND PAINFUL FOR
EVERYONE SHE WROTE.
IN THE END IT WAS PERSONAL AND
PAINFUL WATCHING HIM DIE.
AND I WAS GOOD BECAUSE YOUR
RACISM KILLED GEORGE FLOYD.
THAT WAS NIKKI HALEY'S FIRST
REACTION SHE READ IT IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AND SHE
BELIEVE THAT THEY ALL DO.
SO IT SHOULDN'T SHOCK YOU AT THE
FIRST REACTION TO THE RUSSIA
INVASION IN A FIRST REACTION OF
SO MANY OTHER REPUBLICAN LEADERS
WAS THE PROTECTING UKRAINE IS
WAY MORE IMPORTANT THAN
PROTECTING YOU.
THAN PROTECTING AMERICA TO MITCH
McCONNELL TO HIS CREDIT HAS
MOVED FROM THAT.
HE STILL THINKS IT.
HERE HE WAS YESTERDAY.
>> I THINK WE ALL AGREED THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING GOING ON IN
THE WORLD RIGHT NOW IS THE WORN
UKRAINE.
I DO CHANCE TO CALL THE
PRESIDENT LAST WEEK AND REQUEST
THAT THE UKRAINE PACKAGE MOVED
BY ITSELF AND QUICKLY.
HE SAID LET ME THINK IT OVER HE
CALLED BACK ABOUT 15 MINUTES AND
AGREED THAT WE NEED TO DO THIS
FOR UKRAINE ONLY AND QUICKLY.
I THINK RUN OF THE PATH TO
GETTING THAT DONE.
>> Tucker: YOU HAVE TO HOPE
THAT THERE'S SOME SINCERE
BILLIONAIRE OUT THERE WHO'S
GONNA FUND A PRIMARY CHALLENGE
AND GET EVERY SINGLE OF THOSE
REPUBLICAN SENATORS STANDING BY
MITCH McCONNELL THAT I THINK
WE ALL AGREE THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING GOING ON THE WALL RIGHT
NOW IS THE WAR IN UKRAINE.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING IN THE
WORLD RIGHT NOW IS THE STATE OF
YOUR COUNTRY, THE ONE YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO RUN.
THE PEOPLE YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO
REPRESENT WHOSE LIVES ARE
SUPPOSED TO CARE ABOUT THEM WHEN
YOU CAN'T BUY FOOD OR GAS.
PEOPLE BEING ON FENTON ALL.
HUNDRED AND 7,000 IN A YEAR
DEAD, YOU DEAD PEOPLE.
WE ALL AGREE THAT UKRAINE IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING.
IF YOU AGREE WITH THAT YOU
SHOULD NOT BE SITTING IN THE
UNITED STATES SENATOR AS A
REPUBLICAN.
AND YET THAT'S THEIR POSITION.
OF COURSE IT'S LINDSEY GRAHAM'S
POSITION JUST TO GIVE YOU
ANOTHER EXAMPLE.
>> IF YOU STILL SITTING AFTER
ALL OF THIS THAN THE WORLD'S CAN
BE A VERY DARK PLACE AND CHINA'S
CAN TO GET THE WRONG SIGNAL AND
WILL HAVE A MESS ON OUR HANDS IN
EUROPE FOR DECADES TO COME.
SO LET'S TAKE OUT VLADIMIR PUTIN
BY HELPING OUT UKRAINE.
>> THIS ENDS WITH M PUTIN BEING
REMOVED?
>> THERE IS NO OFFERING FOR HIM.
>> Tucker: IT'S WEIRD TO SEE
SOMEONE TAKE OFF THEIR LIFE
FANTASIES ON TV.
WE SPEND THE NEXT HOUR THEN
GOING BACK 20 YEARS MAKING
PREDICTIONS THAT INCOME TRUE
THAT ONLY RESULTED IN THE DEATH
OF AMERICAN SERVICEMEN IN THE
IMPOVERISHMENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
HE'S BEEN WRONG EVERY SINGLE
TIME HE STILL OUT THERE.
LET'S JUST TAKE OUT
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
THEY HAVE 6,000 NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
WITH A BE UNSECURED?
DO YOU THINK WE HAVE A MESS ON
OUR HANDS WHEN SADDAM HUSSEIN'S
ONE OF THE HANDS OF EXTREMISTS.
WHAT IF WE JUST TOOK OUT PUTIN.
DON'T EVEN THINK ABOUT IT THEY
DON'T CARE.
THERE ARE HIGH ON OWN SUPPLY.
NOT A STUPID GUY, INVESTING IN
THE MILITARY WHEN WE SPENT
$40 BILLION.
INVESTING IN THE DESTRUCTION OF
OUR ADVERSARIES AND MILITARIES
WHEN WE DECLARE WAR ON RUSSIA?
DOES ANYONE VOTE FOR THAT
ADVERSARIES MILITARY THAT'S WHAT
YOU DO IN WAR.
SINCE WHEN ARE WE FIGHTING
RUSSIA?
SINCE FIND PUTIN STOLE THE
ELECTION FROM HILLARY CLINTON IS
GOOD TO SEE THAT DAN CRENSHAW
SIGNED UP FOR THIS.
WE HAVE TO WONDER AT WHAT COST?
NOT JUST APPAREL BUT THE REAL
PERIL THAT THIS COULD ESCALATE
INTO SOMETHING CRUSHING FOR THE
WEST BUT WHAT IMMEDIATE COST TO
THE UNITED STATES AS OUR OWN
ABILITY TO DEFEND OURSELVES.
DO THEY EVER ASK THAT QUESTION?
RIGHT NOW, JOE BIDEN IN THE U.S.
CONGRESS AS SENT SO MUCH
MILITARY AID THAT OUR COUNTRY OF
THE UNITED STATES IS RUNNING OUT
OF WEAPONS.
ACCORDING TO BLOOMBERG OFFICIALS
SAY THAT KEY F IS GOING TO A
WEEK'S WORTH OF DELIVERIES EVERY
DAY.
SOCIAL RUNNING SHORT AS RUSSIAN
AIR STRIKES TAKE THEIR TOLL.
AMMUNITION HAS BECOME SCARCE IN
THE AREAS OF UKRAINE.
THIS IS PRESENTING WESTERN
COUNTRIES WITH A STARK CHOICE
BETWEEN POURING MORE SUPPLIES
INTO UKRAINE OR HUSBANDING
FINITE CAPABILITIES THEY MAY
NEED FOR THEIR OWN DEFENSE.
THAT'S THE LINE.
THEY MIGHT NEED FOR THEIR OWN
DEFENSE IT'S A SCARY WORLD IF
YOU BLOW IT ALL IN UKRAINE AT
FINITE RESOURCES LIKE WE HAVE.
WHAT DOES THAT LEAVE YOU?
UNDEFENDED.
THIS IS HAPPENING BECAUSE SENIOR
LEADERS OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
INSTANTLY ABOUT
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" POSITION ON
UKRAINE.
THE INSTANTLY ABOUT THE
POSITION.
THEY DIDN'T QUESTION WHAT THEY
READ AND THE CONSEQUENCES NOW WE
ARE SHORT ON WEAPONS TO DEFEND
OUR OWN COUNTRY.
NO DEMOCRAT GOES AGAINST THEIR
OWN HERD EVER.
THE FIRST REACTION OF ANY
DEMOCRAT IS TO READ WHATEVER
TALKING POINTS NANCY PELOSI
PROVIDES THEY NEVER READ THE
OTHER SIDE.
THEY ALWAYS GO FARTHER IN ONE
DIRECTION AND THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY HAS ALWAYS LED BY PEOPLE.
HERE FOR EXAMPLE IS HOW
CONGRESSMAN THEY RESPONDED WHEN
GEORGIA RAISED AN OBJECTION WHAT
ABOUT OUR COUNTRY'S HE SAID
HERE'S HE SAID BACK.
>> $40 BILLION BUT THERE'S NO
BABY FORMULA FOR AMERICAN
MOTHERS AND BABIES AN UNKNOWN
AMOUNT OF MONEY TO THE CIA AND
THE UKRAINIAN SUPPLEMENTAL BILL
BUT THERE IS NO FORMULA FOR
AMERICAN BABIES AND MOTHERS.
WE SHOULD BE PAYING ATTENTION TO
OUR COUNTRY RIGHT NOW.
>> THE YOUNG LADY YIELDS BACK
THE GENTLEMAN FROM MINNESOTA.
>> THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
HERE'S A FORMULA FOR THE
DESTRUCTION OF DEMOCRACY
REPEATING FLAVOR PRUDENCE AND
DISINFORMATION AND APPEASING
IMPERIALISTIC ASSAULTS ON
SOVEREIGN NATIONS.
>> Tucker: SO YOU CAN'T BUY
BABY FORMULA IN THE
UNITED STATES AND MAYBE YOU
THINK YOU CAN DO BOTH AT ONCE
YOU CAN FIND UKRAINE AND GET
BABY FORMULA FOR AMERICAN
BABIES.
MAYBE HE CAN FIX INFLATION AND
ALSO FIND UKRAINE.
MAYBE THERE IS AN ANSWER TO THE
QUESTION BUT MOST OF IT THEY
DON'T ANSWER.
IT IS TO CHOOSE THE PERSON
ASKING THE QUESTION OF WORKING
FOR VLADIMIR PUTIN.
YOU'RE AGAINST DEMOCRACY.
DON'T TELL US HOW UKRAINIANS
HAVE DEMOCRACY THEY BAN THE
OPPOSITION PARTY THAT'S
DEMOCRACY.
BUT MAYBE THERE'S AN ANSWER WHAT
IS IT?
STOP NAME-CALLING AND ANSWER THE
QUESTION.
NONE OF THEM WILL.
HE'S CRAZY ABOUT VLADIMIR PUTIN.
57 REPUBLICANS DID VOTE AGAINST
LAST NIGHTS BILL AND GOD BLESS
THEM FOR DOING IT.
BUT MANY MORE VOTED FOR IT OF
COURSE THERE WAS LIZ CHENEY.
THERE WAS ALSO REPUBLICAN
LEADERSHIP.
TOP LEADERSHIP.
SHAMEFUL.
AND THE WORST PART IS THIS BILL
WILL ALMOST CERTAINLY PASS IN
THE SENATE WHICH IS WAY MORE
LEFT WING EVEN IN THE HOUSE ON
THE REPUBLICAN SIDE.
IT IS PROBABLY THINKING SWIFT
VOTE ON IT WHICH IS AS SOON AS
TOMORROW.
SO WE REACHED OUT TO EVERY
REPUBLICAN IN THE SENATE THE
FINAL WITH A PLAN TO DO MOST OF
THEM DIDN'T BOTHER TO REPLY AND
NONE OF THEM WILL COME ON THE
SHOW EXCEPT MITCH McCONNELL
THE MINORITY LEADER, TED CRUZ
AND MITT ROMNEY ALSO DID NOT
RESPOND.
WERE HOPING TO VOTE THE RIGHT
WAY.
BUT A HANDFUL OF SENATORS DID
RESPOND AND WE WANT TO LET YOU
KNOW WHERE THEY STAND.
RAND PAUL HAS OPPOSED TO IT BUT
HE IS AGAINST IT.
HE'S THROUGH.
AS HIS OFFICE THROUGH.
HE SUPPORTS ADDITIONAL MILITARY
AID UKRAINE.
HE DIDN'T SAY THAT BUT THAT'S
THE TRUTH.
ROB PORTMAN OF OHIO SO IS
MONTANA.
THE SENATE IS LEADING YES.
THEY THINK THAT RUSSIAN
OLIGARCHS SOMEHOW WILL PAY THE
40 BILLION.
HE WANTS TO MAKE RUSSIA COVER
THE COSTS AND HE WANTS USE TO
SEIZE ASSETS TO COVER THE COST.
RIGHT OKAY.
A FEW SENATORS DODGED.
THEY ALL REFUSED TO GIVE US A
DIRECT ANSWER.
WE WANT TO INVITE ANY REPUBLICAN
SENATORS WHO PLAN ON VOTING TO
THIS TO COME ON THE SHOW AND ITS
PLAIN WHITE.
PLEASE TELL US WHAT YOU TALK AS
MUCH AS YOU WANT.
ROCK AND A SANDBAG YOU WE WANT
TO KNOW WHY THIS IS AN AMERICANS
INTERESTWISE IS MORE IMPORTANT
THAN THE PRESSING CRISIS A